president biden is cheering a
long-awaited victory a more than
trillion dollar bill to upgrade
america's infrastructure is finally on
his desk house democrats and some
republicans approved it on friday after
keeping it on hold for months nancy
cordes is at the white house with more
on this and what's coming up next next
is how you say that word nancy good
morning to you
good morning gail yeah the white house
was in full celebration mode this
weekend not only was this infrastructure
bill central to the biden agenda but it
was a rare bipartisan victory and
something that multiple presidents have
tried and failed to do over the weekend
president biden said that americans
should start to see the effects in the
next couple of months as shovel ready
projects get underway this is a bill
just a reminder that provides hundreds
of billions of dollars to build and
repair roads and bridges modernize rail
and public transit strengthen the
electrical grid expand broadband access
and upgrade water pipes and a lot more
it passed the house just before midnight
on friday after months of negotiations
and democrats are really hoping it's
going to help shore up some of the
president's poll numbers after the party
took a series of hits in state elections
last week gail
yeah a lot of people on the struggle bus
to get this done but nancy moving on
what are the prospects now for the
president's other big priority you know
that big social spending bill it
includes stuff like universal pre-k what
are you hearing about that
well there is a group of centrist
democrats gail who say they do not want
to vote on that bill until they get
confirmation from the non-partisan
congressional budget office the cbo
that it's going to cost what the white
house says it will cost so i asked the
president about that over the weekend
take a listen to what he had to say
have you gotten assurances from moderate
democrats in the house and senate that
they are going to vote for your build
back better plan now that what they
really wanted the infrastructure bill
has passed you know i'm not going to
answer that question for you
because i'm not going to get into who
what made what commitments to me i don't
negotiate in public but i feel confident
i feel confident that we will have
enough votes to pass the bill back
better plan what gives you that
confidence
me
he plans to take that confidence on the
road this week to the port of baltimore
where he will tout his infrastructure
plan meanwhile democrats have
tentatively arranged to hold a vote on
the build back better plan next week if
they can get the cost estimates by then
as you can imagine gail it takes time
for the number crunchers to sift through
all of this material when you're talking
about a two trillion dollar bill that
has comp been compared to fdr's new deal
well nancy there was a lot of confidence
in that answer me very simple thank you
very much